salut les amis bonjour bonjour bonjour
tout le monde aujourd'hui c'est
l'anniversaire du Président c'est
l'anniversaire d'Emmanuel Macron
aujourd'hui c'est l'hiver également dans
chaque pièce la température est fixée à
19 degrés y compris dans le bureau du
ministre 19 il a bien la bonne consigne
pas de problème et là c'est la
température actuelle du bureau 20,7
température ambiante près de 2 degrés
au-dessus des recommandations ce soir là
Blanche-Neige revisité avec des
dialogues pour les adultes moi je n'ai
pas peur du noir moi non plus vu le
montant des factures d'énergie c'est
plutôt la lumière qui me fait peur il
peut faire plus de 19 degrés dans mon
bureau c'est vrai même si le chauffage
est mis à 19 degrés il suffit que vous
ayez fait une réunion avec beaucoup de
personnes il suffit surtout que vous
veniez à midi ici qu'en soleil tape je
peux vous dire que même l'hiver ça fait
monter la température en revanche une
certitude aussi c'est que le matin quand
j'arrive il fait pour moi de 19 degrés
il y a des chercheurs du CNRS qui ont
démontré que quelqu'un qui mentait avait
des signes très distinctifs par exemple
un rythme plus lent dans les paroles on
va s'apercevoir aussi qui va mettre des
très faibles intonations sur les deux
premières syllables ça va manquer de
puissance et puis la dernière chose
c'est qu'on entend à la fin de sa phrase
qui laisse sa voix un peu en l'air et ça
c'est typique du mensonge 200000
personnes ont reçu ou vont recevoir
aujourd'hui un message indiquant que
leur train de ce week-end est supprimé à
cause du mouvement de grève des
contrôleurs à la SNCF qui réclament une
augmentation de salaire la direction de
la compagnie ferroviaire en tant
compensé et annonce que les voyageurs
ainsi impactés seront remboursés le
double du montant de leur billet mon
train pour Nantes
mon train du 25 décembre est supprimé ce
n'est pas grave je prendrai l'avion le
souci c'est qu'il n'y a plus d'avion
entre Paris et Nantes la ligne n'existe
plus comme n'existeront plus bientôt les
lignes aériennes entre 2000 françaises
ce n'est pas bon pour la planète je suis
vraiment sur l'énergie je suis gonflé
non non il va me casser les bonbons je
le vois arriver non non j'ai le seum
mais le seum mais j'ai une haine ça
perturbe tout le monde les gens voient
de beauté chez eux c'est nul quoi
sur le côté on peut utiliser pour
frotter aussi on a un autre une autre
valise
qui nous fait office de
maracas vous savez ce que je vous dis la
SNCF empêcher les étudiants qui
travaillent jusqu'au 24 de retrouver
leur famille pour Noël c'est juste
lamentable
le résultat est bluffant
Noël c'est le moment vous retrouvez la
famille le moment vous retrouvez les
enfants les parents les grands-parents
les amis c'est le moment où vous avez
besoin de vous déplacer pour beaucoup de
Français c'est parfois d'ailleurs le
seul moment où ils prennent le train
dans l'année et c'est pas le moment où
on fait grève c'est pas le week-end de
Noël où on choisit de faire grève mais
une fois le billet annulé est remboursé
comment partir en vacances et là j'ai
pris un covoiturage
le covoit je pense que tout est complet
et même j'ai pas envie de la covoiturage
à noter spectateur je pense que
quelqu'un peut se dévouer pour vous
emmener quelque part
il est aussi grand que vous
peut-être même plus
davantage
c'est que vous trouvez les news il y a
40 ans jour pour jour donc vous avez pas
la grève
en Grande-Bretagne apparemment donc
c'était déjà voilà Grande Bretagne
Madame Thatcher bref quand tu vois le
comportement qu'ils ont ben là je vais
dire les mêmes mecs qui tapent sur les
études que le gouvernement fait chez
mckinzey pour savoir comment il faut
régler des problèmes mais pas la peine
de faire une étude là je vais dire un
truc hein ce qui va ressortir c'est que
comment casser le monopole de la SNCF
pour arriver vers un service ou au fond
on va privatiser encore ce service
public ce beau service public
mais qu'est-ce que c'est que c'est
diablotins c'est sorciers j'ai peur
heureusement que le Père Noël qui est
avec nous quand même euh ouais pour les
syndicats la situation est intenable
croisons que les établissements et
salariés de nos établissements sont dans
le dur et une fois de plus on va leur
supprimer leurs congés je trouve ça
quand même fort grave on est foutu tu
vas dans un pays t'as pas un mégot qui
traîne t'as pas un tapis crête
attendez
une démocratie avec un régime
autoritaire enfin ils ont pas eu le
sentiment d'être dans un pays
autoritaire pendant un mois pour les
gens qui sont pas
unisexuel par exemple homosexuels
avardée qui a 20 ans qui a été arrêté
dans les manifestations et qui est
condamné à mort écoutez-moi bien pour
corruption terrestre et inimitié avec
Dieu